[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENT CANDILLIER: OK, Google.
So what's next?
At Ocado Technology, we
could answer robots and AI.
Here are some of our
robots and here is
one of our huge
warehouses full of robots
running to pick up
goods to fulfill
thousands of orders per day.
You might wonder
who is Ocado now?
Ocado has been an online
retailer in UK since 15 years.
As a customer, you can go
to our website or our app
to place your order.
We can help you do
so by recommending
some of your regular
products or new ones.
And maybe one day,
a self-driving car
will reach you home.
But meanwhile, thousands
of pickers and drivers
are working to make this happen.
Ocado is also now more
than just a retailer.
It's also a tech company, robust
enough to share its technology.
So we can share with you,
if you're a retailer,
from the website and the app
to the full system of delivery
using our fully automated
warehouses and more
big data and AI.
Some of the biggest
retailers in the world
are already with us
on this adventure,
like Morrisons in UK, Bon Preu
in Spain, Casino in France,
Sobeys in Canada, ICA in Sweden,
and Kroger here in the United
States.
OK, now let's turn to some
examples of machine learning
and AI that can help this
online retail business.
Product recognition-- for
now, our pickers, our robots,
need to find where the
barcode of the products
are in order to identify
them for picking.
Using image recognition, we
could speed up this process
and improve its accuracy
by just bypassing
the problem of needing to
find where the barcode is.
And there is more.
With such technology, we could
also provide to the customer
the possibility to just take
photos of the products they
want to add to their baskets.
Another example of machine
learning that can be used
is for demand forecasting.
To deliver thousands of
orders per day properly,
we need to anticipate
the demand.
How many orders will
be placed every day?
That can change during
the week, the weekend,
during holidays, or most
especially, on Christmas.
And if you can also
more precisely predict
how many products of each kind
will be demanded every day,
you will also better
anticipate the supply chain.
And in these kind of problems,
machine learning can help.
For example, product
recommendation.
Have you run out of some
of your regular products?
Would you also like some
complimentary products
with the one in your baskets?
Would you rather like one
product instead of another one?
Machine learning can help.
And a last example that
we will detail more
into this presentation
is a classical problem
that we face in online retail,
that is fraud detection.
Orders are being delivered
but never paid for,
or being delivered, paid
for, but then the money
is required back.
This is called chargeback.
And this happens, in general,
when the credit card used
was a stolen one.
OK, now let's enter into
more detail into this fraud
detection problem and
start setting the context.
Ocado retail in UK is
more than 50,000 products,
more than 650,000 customers,
more than 250,000 orders
per week.
So imagine you only have
one failed payment out
of 1,000 orders,
it already means
losing millions of dollars.
On the other hand,
if you can improve
just by a few percentage
your fraud detection system,
you can save tens of
thousands of dollars.
With one big warning,
false positive.
If you predict that one
order will be fraudulent
and it's not because
it's a regular customer,
this has higher costs, because
a regular customer that
will stop buying with you is a
lot of possible future orders
that you are losing,
and not just one,
and possibly some fail.
And so I told you,
now we have on board
much more retailers from
all around the world.
So these numbers just multiply.
OK, so how can we face this kind
of problem of fraud detection?
Historically, we have been
using a set of handmade rules,
set of rules, like
for example, if you
place more than three orders
for the future for more than 500
pounds and you let us less
than 24 hours for the delivery,
well, your order is risky.
You combine a lot
of rules like that,
you give a score that gives a
risk potential of your orders.
So this kind of system
is based on intuitions,
human intuitions.
Humans can, in general,
define 10, 20, 30
rules based on 10, 20 features.
Each rule is based on
1, 2, 3, 4 conditions.
And in general, it's kind
of fixed set of rules.
Other possible approach
is machine learning.
If you derive features
from your incoming orders,
like how many first orders
of the customer, what's
the total amount of
your baskets, what's
the time between the order
and the delivery, and you
pass all these features
along with the known class
of failed payments or not to a
machine learning algorithm that
will learn a model,
that will then
be able to predict if a
new incoming order will
be associated with
failed payments or not.
This system is based on
data instead of intuitions
and can handle much more
rules, much more features,
much more condition on rules.
And it is adaptable.
You can relearn regularly
your machine learning model,
and it will take into account
the last behavior of fraudster
that can evolve with time.
OK, so we ran some analysis
on the different machine
learning algorithm available.
And I put here on two axes
the results that we have.
On the vertical axis is
the predictive performance
of the models.
And extra boosts,
like many times
in Kaggle competition
and real life exhibits,
is reaching the best
predictive performance.
And then TensorFlow
neural network
has also interesting results.
And I put on the horizontal
axis another aspect
that is important
in fraud detection.
That is explainability.
If your algorithm
can explain why
he thinks that one order is
fraudulent or not, for example,
because the content of
the basket is not normal,
or if the payment methods
used seems suspicious,
it will help the human.
And if you want to use this
machine learning algorithm
to make automated decisions
for legal reasons,
you need to explain why
it rejected one order.
So obviously, on
these certain aspects,
the handmade rules are the best.
It's more understandable
for humans.
But the rule induction
algorithms are really close.
Decision tree also
are understandable,
but sometimes the depth of the
tree is too high for a human
to really apprehend it.
OK, here is a really
important thing.
I am a data scientist.
I know quite a lot about machine
learning, neural networks,
how to cluster data,
deduplicate data, how
to face an unbalanced
class problem,
how to configure parameters of
neural networks, all of those,
but I don't know quite anything
about machine settings,
networks topology, clustering
machine, replicate data, load
balancing, configure server.
So the main question
here is, how can I
now go from my big data lying
some data lake into a fully
automated pipeline of machine
learning serving predictions
for fraud detection in
production, hopefully
easily and quickly,
but most importantly,
scaling and with
no need to set up
a lot of machines and containers
and auto-scaling processes, et
cetera.
With one main constraint,
that is real time.
Fraudsters don't lose time.
If they steal a
credit card, they
will try to use it to place
five orders for a high amount
and for short notice.
So imagine we have a model that
just used two features-- how
many past orders for the
customer and how many
future orders for the customer.
At training time, it's easy.
We have the access to all data.
We can deride the
future from the inputs,
pass it to the machine
learning model algorithm that
will learn a model.
At serving time now, it
can be more complicated.
The number of past
orders can be something
that has been pre-computed and
exposed to get the information
directly at real time.
The number of future orders
can be more complicated,
because since the fraudster
can place a lot in real time,
you need to be
closer to real time.
So you need one set of features
pre-computed, another one
in real time, and combine
them to provide as inputs
to the machine learning
model exactly the same
as training time.
So [INAUDIBLE],, do you
have some good solution
to handle my problems and
maybe with some Google tools?
PRZEMYSLAW PASTUSZKA:
Thank you, Laurent.
I will try to do just that.
First of all, thank
you for coming.
And we will now see how we
can implement the solution
for a fraud detection problem
using Google Cloud Platform.
And of course, as
Laurent said, we
would like it to be
as easy as possible.
So let's do this.
Well, first of all,
I would like you
to imagine where we want to
be at the end of the journey.
What are the actual
physical components
that will be in play here?
So on the left side
here, what you can see
is order management
microservice.
Ocada's smart platform
is powered by hundreds
of microservices like this.
Each of them has very clearly
defined responsibility.
And here, as the name
suggests, order management
deals with orders being placed.
This service, when the
order is being placed,
would like to know whether this
order is fraudulent or not.
So what it will do, it will
consult other microservice--
let's call it fraud service--
by sending it customer ID and
all details about the order.
And what it would
like to get in return
is what is the probability of
this order being fraudulent?
And the fraud service is
actually the component
that we are trying to build.
So please keep
this image in mind.
So this is where
we are heading to.
What if you've never done
machine learning project?
How would you even start?
Where do you begin?
So of course, there is no
machine learning without data.
You need a fair
amount of history
to be able to learn
patterns from the behaviors
of your customers.
To do that, you need
the right set of tools
to store and process the data.
And since we're talking
about Google Cloud Platform,
there is a really good
analytical database
that we would like to use.
And it's Google BigQuery.
We, as Ocado, store all
our data in BigQuery.
So it's petabytes
of data, actually.
And BigQuery scales to
this amount seamlessly.
The other thing that we
really like about BigQuery
is that how fast it is.
We can write SQL queries, run
them over terabytes of data,
and still get results in terms
of minutes or even seconds.
The other good thing
is that it doesn't
require you to have separate
DBA team to manage BigQuery.
You just load data into
BigQuery, you run queries,
and that's all that is there.
And the last thing that
kind of sold BigQuery to us
is the pricing policy.
In BigQuery, you
pay for storage.
And in terms of SQL
queries, you pay
for the amount of data
those queries have read.
So it's a very fair
policy and really
helps us to control
the cost that we
spend on doing analytics.
And there are two
questions remaining.
So we decided that we ought to
use BigQuery as a main storage.
So the first question
is, how do we actually
load the data in BigQuery?
And the one which is
even more fundamental,
what data you land in BigQuery?
So in the data lake, you would
like to store all the data,
but what all means in this case?
So the rule of thumb that we
use in Ocado which is really
working very well for
us is that when there
is any change to the business
state of the application,
you should send, or
rather your microservice
responsible for
that business state
should send an event to
a distributed queue which
corresponds to the change.
When we gather all the
data of the small deltas,
then when we go
back in time, you
are able to see what
was the exact state
of the whole system at any
particular point in time.
So here is the diagram of
the ingestion pipeline.
On the left, you see
all those microservices
that I told you about.
They are actually running
in Amazon Web Services.
And we use AWS Kinesis
for distributive queue.
Then there is a
question, how do we
transport data from a
distributed queue to BigQuery?
And we wrote a
streaming application
using Apache Beam
and Google Dataflow,
which is running 24/7.
And it's moving the
data in real time.
And then we used streaming
inserts into BigQuery
to store this data.
If you don't know what Apache
Beam or Google Dataflow is,
let me spend a few minutes on
telling you more about this.
For that, I will
use a toy example.
Let's imagine you have
a collection of words.
Maybe you took a
Shakespeare novel
and you split it to have an each
word that isn't in this novel.
And you would like to
count how many of those
words start with the letter
A, or letter B, C, et cetera.
If you were to write this using,
for example, Java Streams,
you would probably
write a snippet
like the one on the top.
You would first extract
first character out
of each word, group
by this character,
and then for each
group count the amount
of items in this group.
And in Apache Beam,
it's very similar.
You just write exactly
the same transformations.
You have a map which
extracts first character out
of the word, you group
by, and then you count.
And Apache Beam is just
a programming model
for transforming the data.
It kind of like a Java Streams,
because how it actually
executes is dependent on
JVM in case of Java Streams.
And it's the same way with beam.
You just write this
code, and how you execute
it depends on the execution
framework that you choose.
And there are plenty of
executions for a framework
that you can choose from,
ranging from Apache Apex
to Apache Gearpump.
The one that use
is Google Dataflow,
mostly because it's well
integrated with other Google
Cloud Services.
But it's also semi-managed.
You still have control over
machine's configuration,
but most of the time, you
just write the Java code,
you upload to Google
Dataflow, and it just runs.
Right, we have all
our data in BigQuery.
So the next app that Laurent
or anyone working on machine
learning algorithm
would do is probably
to go there and explore
what data's available.
You need to see what
are the distributions
of different variables,
how different tables join
with each other.
You can ask different
questions about your data.
For example, you can
ask whether people
that have a lot amount of
alcohol in their orders
are more likely to be fraudsters
than the other people.
And the really great tool to
do that exploratory analysis
is BigQuery, because
first of all, we already
have data there.
It has web UI, where it can
just go, type the query,
and get a result fast.
And based on the results, you
can formulate another query
and iterate, iterate, to
the point where you have all
the answers for your questions.
If you need to do a
more deep analysis,
maybe plot some charts,
share the results
with another people,
there are other tools
in Google Cloud Platform
that allow you to do that.
One I would like to
mention is Google Datalab,
which is basically a
hosted Jupyter notebook.
You write Python code there.
You can extract
data from BigQuery.
You can plot charts
with whatever libraries
that are available in
Python environment.
You can use Pandas.
You can use scikit-learn.
You can use Plotly,
whatever you want.
And there is also another
tool from Google called Google
Collaborator that
you see here, which
is kind of taking this idea
of notebooks one step further.
So in Google Collaborator,
the Jupyter notebook
is just a file on Google Drive.
And you can do whatever you
do with Google Drive files
with Jupyter notebook here.
So you can share it.
You can put comments in here.
Many people can collaborate
on the same notebook
at the same time.
We use it a lot in Ocado,
especially if we're
doing reviews on notebooks.
And we find it very handy.
At this point, we are
ready to jump into ML.
We will do a
feature engineering,
so we'll extract meaningful
information out of raw data,
and we'll train and model.
But first, which
model do you choose?
Here's the slide that
Laurent already showed you.
And Laurent told
you that there are
two things that we care about.
One is accuracy on the y-axis.
And the other one
is explainability,
which you can see
here on the x-axis.
But to be honest, there is also
a third dimension here which
we need to take into account.
And this is how
easy it is to deploy
those solutions to the cloud.
Google Cloud Platform offers
you a cloud machine learning.
This is a service that
was first designed
to train and serve neural
nets, written in TensorFlow.
How this works exactly?
You write your TensorFlow code.
You package it into
a Python package.
You put it on Google
Cloud Storage.
And then you just call it
cloud machine learning API.
You say, here's my
package with TensorFlow.
Here's the input data.
Please train the model for me.
And then the trained
model is just another file
on Google Cloud Storage.
So then you can point cloud
machine learning to this model.
And you can say,
please serve it for me.
So what cloud machine
learning will do,
it will create a REST endpoint
that you can call in real time.
You just give it
all the features
and you get predictions back.
Sometime ago, Google announced
that cloud machine learning
will support other algorithms,
except of TensorFlow.
So there is support
for serving XGBoost
and scikit-learn models.
Unfortunately, there is no way
to train them yet on the cloud.
And of course, you
can use CPUs, GPUs
for training all this stuff.
So to sum up, the
neural networks
are now really easy to
deploy to the cloud thanks
to cloud machine learning.
It's not so easy when it comes
to XGBoost and scikit-learn,
because you still need to
take care of the training
by yourself.
And if you were to use the
rule induction, the C5 program,
which it was written in C++, we
really have no out of the box
way to run it on the cloud.
If we were to do this,
we would probably
package it into a
Docker container,
run on Google Container
Engine with Kubernetes.
But this will
require a lot of work
from us, lot of fine tuning.
So given all of
that information,
we made a conscious decision
that we will sacrifice
explainability for now.
So it's not that we
don't care about it,
but to get us faster
to production,
we'll start with something which
is easy to deploy to the cloud.
And since neural nets are
easy to deploy and still
have pretty good accuracy,
this is what we went for.
All, right so we have
chosen the ML model.
It's now time to train it.
And here's how the
training pipeline
looks like on the high level.
So we have events that
I told you about before.
So each corresponds
to the single change
to the business state
of the application.
Out of those, we need to
extract meaningful information.
For example, how many failed
transactions did this customer
have in the past?
And for that, we use
primarily BigQuery.
So we wrote SQL queries
THAT transform this data
and store them in BigQuery
as a set of tables.
At some point, so that those
SQL became hard to manage,
so that we decided to
rewrite some of those
transformations into Dataflow,
again, using Apache Beam.
And when we have all
of these in BigQuery,
we can just run
Cloud ML training
and obtain a trained model.
Of course, in the
machine learning,
it's very rare
case that you just
train a model once and deploy.
Usually, what you do is
you refresh the model.
And to do that, you need some
way to schedule and orchestrate
your training pipeline.
When we started with
GCP five years back,
there was no out
of the box solution
ready in Google Cloud
Platform, so we wrote our own.
We called it Query Manager, and
it's an app engine application
that takes care of all of that.
Fortunately for you, if
you are starting right now,
there is now hosted
Apache Airflow,
which goes by the name
Google Cloud Composer.
It's currently in
beta, but I highly
encourage you to
go and try it out.
So what we do, we schedule our
training pipeline to run daily.
And each day we
have a fresh model.
And the one piece
left is that we
need to serve this
model in real time.
So let's see how
we do this exactly.
Just to recall, this
is where we want to be.
Order Management
application, as you remember,
sends the customer ID and
order detail to Fraud Service,
and Fraud Service returns
probability of this order
being fraudulent.
How do we connect that with
Cloud Machine Learning?
One idea is maybe
the fraud service
will just send the
features to Cloud Machine
Learning in real time
and we'll get a response,
and it will just pass it
back to Order Management.
The one problem here is that
Fraud Service doesn't know
all the features at this point.
So it knows what's the
current order of the customer,
but it doesn't know what was the
past behavior of the customer.
So we need to somehow
obtain this data.
If you recall, we have
already calculated
all of this in BigQuery,
so we have all the features
about the past behavior
of the customer ready,
sitting there in BigQuery.
So maybe we'll just
make Fraud Service
to call BigQuery, get the data
for this particular customer,
and then combine it
with current order data
and pass it along to
Cloud Machine Learning.
Again, the one problem
for that is BigQuery
was not really designed
for random access patterns.
Going to BigQuery, finding
a row corresponding
to a particular customer would
be extremely inefficient.
And we cannot afford to do this.
What we need is some
kind of persistent cache
that will sit between BigQuery
and the Fraud Service.
So what we used, we
used Google Datastore.
Google Datastore is
NoSQL document database.
So you put entities
there with no schema.
You can easily search for them.
You can have SQLite
queries over them.
But we don't really use
all of those features.
What we do is we use Google
Datastore as a key value store.
So we put the data about
customers as a key value pair.
Key is the customer
ID, and the value
is all the features
for this customer.
So now how do we
populate the datastore?
We simply extended
the training pipeline,
so when the features
are calculated,
we also use Google Dataflow
to transport these features
from BigQuery to Datastore.
And this is done in Dataflow
with Apache Beam again.
Since Apache Beam
already has connectors
to BigQuery and
Datastore, writing
a program which does this data
transformation was really easy.
It's just 40 or
50 lines of code.
And it runs in a batch mode
and transports the data
to a datastore.
If we combine all the pieces
together, training and serving,
this is what we end up with.
If you look at the bottom
of the serving part,
we, again, have Order Management
sending current features
to a fraud service,
which calls Datastore
to obtain the past features.
Then it combines it and
pass along to Cloud ML,
get the response back.
So this is how it works.
And we were pretty happy
with this architecture.
The one problem here is that
the datastore is populated
every day, right?
It's not populated
every few seconds.
Only when the training
pipeline runs.
So again, the problem
that Laurent described
when a fraudster
steals a credit card
and she or he will try
to put many transactions
in a tiny time window,
we will simply not
notice this behavior
in our features.
So we had to do a little hack.
And this is the
final architecture
for serving that is working
on production right now.
So Fraud Service
now gets the data
from Order Management,
current order.
It gets past features one
day old from a datastore.
But it also queries
other microservices
for the latest data
about the customer.
So it's all done in real time.
And only then Fraud Service
combines all of this,
sends request to Cloud
Machine Learning,
and gets response back.
All right, this is how our
architecture looks like.
And now, Laurent, can you tell
us a bit more about the results
that we got?
LAURENT CANDILLIER: Sure.
Thank you, [INAUDIBLE].
That's great.
Basically, we have all
what we need to run
machine running on the cloud.
I can start with simple feature
engineering in Google BigQuery,
where my data lies, extract
some simple feature,
like counting the past
behavior of a customer,
joining some tables.
If I need to do more
complex data processing,
I can use Google Apache
Beam in Google Dataflow.
For example, normalization.
I have to do a
loop on my columns,
compute the average and standard
deviation on numerical columns
to compute my normalized values.
On categorical features,
do some transformation,
like [INAUDIBLE] coding, for
example, or just, as I say,
integers to the categories.
And yeah, these
are some processing
that would have
been too complicated
to do in standard SQL.
And with Google
Dataflow, it's easy.
Next step, I can use Datastore
as the fastest access
to expose my pre-computed
feature that I will then
use at serving time.
I use Google Cloud ML
Engine to do my training
of machine learning models.
And OK, let's use
neural networks.
That is a good
conscious decision
to go quickly on production
and get the best of all what
is offered us by Google Cloud.
Once I have trained my model,
I can easily expose it, again,
through Google
Cloud ML Engine API,
and combine it with what
I exposed in Datastore
of my pre-computed feature.
I can now run my prediction of
fraud detection in real time.
So that's really great.
And we are reaching really
great results with all these.
Obviously, if you
can imagine, if you
compare the machine running
algorithms with neural nets
with the initial solution
that we had of handmade rules,
the results are
really, really better.
When I said predictive
performance already,
it's not about accuracy,
because hopefully,
failed payment is a rare event.
Imagine you have one
fraud out of 100 orders.
If you use accuracy to compute
your predictive performance,
the model that will
just say nothing
is fraud would
have 99% accuracy.
In this kind of
unbalanced class problem,
we use other measures, like
F score or area under the ROC
curve that try to find a
trade-off between precision
and recall.
Recall being the
percentage of real fraud
that your algorithm
managed to identify.
And precision being
among the one that
identified as fraud, what's the
percentage of right prediction
in this one?
With machine learning, we
also gain adaptability.
We can relearn
regularly our models,
and take it to account the
new behavior of fraudsters.
And yeah, we are taking
the best of the cloud here,
and we are already
ready to scale
with all this architecture.
OK, so now we have
a great system
to predict if an order
will be fraudulent or not.
What do we do with that?
What is the final
decision that we take?
Easily, if the order is
identified as non-fraudulent,
you can just let him go
through and avoid friction
with the customer.
This is something that
Ocado really valorates
is just accept the
delivery and just accept
that the payment will
be done afterwards,
because it's good
for the customer.
And it's also easier to handle
when you have some product
substitution, because what
you asked two weeks ago is not
there, so we propose
you something else.
And yeah, it's easier
to handle like that,
and it's customer friendly.
On the other hand,
if the algorithm
says that an order is
probably fraudulent,
what do you do with that?
One possibility is
trigger pre-authorization
on the credit card.
So you reserve the amount
of the order in advance,
and to ensure that
the customer will have
the money at delivery time.
You can also ask the fraud
agents to look at the order
and take the final decision.
And this is where
explanation comes back.
If you can explain
that you think
this order is suspicious for
the content of the basket,
or the past behavior
of the customer,
or the payment methods
used, you can give this
to the fraud agents.
And yeah, if you want to
take this final decision
of canceling an
order automatically,
for legal reasons, you
have to be able to explain.
Basically, I've just presented
you with the good result
that we obtained
on fraud detection.
I'm happy to announce that on
the other projects that we are
running, product recommendation,
demand forecasting,
and product
recognition, we are also
reaching really good results
with an architecture that
is generic enough to
be used in the same way
on different projects.
So yeah, basically, Big
Data Machine Learning
made easy on the cloud.
Thank you, Google.
What's next?
Before taking some ideas and
questions from you, some hints.
We started to play with
Google Dataprep that helps
you pre-visualize the data.
And we find that this
product is really promising.
On the other edge
of the pipeline,
Google Data Studio
is a great solution
to monitor our machine
running, basically plot
the evolution of our precision
and recall of our models.
And there is one work that we
have started with the Google
SRE team to specify some service
level indicators and service
level objective to
ensure the reliability
of our whole system.
Also great.
Thanks a lot for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]